so this is I just call it Nazi
Nutcracker that's what everyone else
calls it uh this I've never seen this
I've heard a lot about it it was
destroyed when it came out like critics
audiences just hated it and I thought so
too
yeah we're Lee enough united the whole
but I don't know how well-known it is I
think it was no one count when it came
out and then kind of vanished but uh
yeah this is one I've been very curious
about cuz how do you fit friggin Nazis
in the Nutcracker I'm aware of its
existence
I have not partaken much like the
Twilight books let's just jump right
into it this is a Nazi Nutcracker also
known as Nutcracker 30 Oh
Beethoven Nutcracker Holdings that's all
wrong Nutcracker already sounds a little
is that Nutcracker holdings is just like
oh but Nazi cracker that's what you call
in the other jokes or just a redneck
Nazi Nazi cracker Christ how many people
made this movie
finally Britain and Hungary together at
last
part of a short-lived alliance that
broke it surely so far cinematography is
amazing and they really pointed cameras
of things what jumps like that
as you can tell I'm not trying it all
for it's not at all pure paycheck we
have just escaped
I feel like this music is just put in
because they kind of have to it's not
really inspiring anything it's just you
know it's conduct cracker - we'll throw
the music it's a little bit of culture
at least to me it looks like those are a
bunch of Gustav Klimt paintings in the
background yeah the sheer number of
those I just have it hanging like next
to the tree in the fireplace like are
you insane
I think we know why we're gonna see
Mouse armies in this if they're all
slide yes you just spiked their meals
it's now a good time to say that I'm
actually not a big Nutcracker guy that
the Nutcracker I'm like yeah it's better
I like it fine I don't love it so
overplayed I agree of the two overplayed
things it's like you've got a Christmas
carol and you've got the Nutcracker and
I would much rather watch a Christmas I
legitimately long Christmas Carol
Nutcracker I never got that into oh my
that sounds like this gunk Wanda Sykes
played and over the hedge Russian Albert
Danko a proper German composes hey he's
not playing anymore
bubi ruined I'm sure what he wrote this
he's like I sure hope people put lyrics
to this it's designed to have lyrics go
to it
did I mention that I don't like the
Nutcracker
you don't despise it I mentioned that
now it's turning into like a killing
spree level of love AKO equals money cut
happy knock off equals cash
it's like Mary Poppins with a creepy old
Nathan Lane who just busts into your
bedroom and starts speaking in a German
accent now you got a problem with that a
spoonful of sugar makes the medicine go
down sit come down and slap the chance
again all right if you really want to
see something amazing you want to see
something amazing recite the
Necronomicon screen I can't look at it
is like just burning a hole through my
soul with those godless godless eyes
protect me Chaplin scary then really
holding on that thing like they're so
convinced it's a good effect I have to
get dressed first I don't have time how
ungrateful men can be Hey the only Tommy
was so directed BC how ungrateful men
can be you're tearing me apart
Nutcracker to do is look at you with no
effort he's terrifying
yes a sexist isn't that cracker is now I
agree with him looking at what she's
wearing that must have taken like an
hour to put
anything so big I have made this for you
now worship me see the way was fuckin
look at this was oh this is fucking
nightmare fuel you know what's so funny
nutcrackers are already creepy and
they're at the big creepy teeth and the
dead eyes how do they move yeah yeah
let's make him cute and some haven't
made a more creep oh it's actually this
is way creepier what the fuck man Mary
is uncle Albert's niece
this is Gilbert Pinker and sticks you
will grow tired of them very shortly and
then throw them in the trash can are you
like the Twilight Zone episode a very
popular one Nutcracker is already a very
loose story you could argue there's
almost no story but what is the story to
this Albert Einstein got them all high
on nitrous oxide finally this music is
set to kazoo as it was meant to be you
look exactly like my mother but I'm not
I'm your other mother
let's see those eyes I would like to say
Tchaikovsky would be rolling in his
grave if you told me about this but most
likely he would just go what's a movie
you're a boy not just a boy a prince I'm
Prince boy put the hooves from that
awful Grinch movie oh you mean the
charming classic-looking who's there
soap you love it and enjoys it's a piece
of shit but because people saw it as
kids are like God's great no no it's
classic rock classic yeah yeah no it's
shit dr. Seuss needed more green Jim
Carrey's in woman's cleavage dr. Seuss
would have wanted that way
let's do this this is really happening
all of them are wondering how did this
happen how did we get in this movie this
moment as they're all standing they
realize what did I say yes I am psychic
[Music]
do I even bother noting that I don't
think the Nazis were into jazz do I like
even put the effort to use a brain cell
to make that connection clearly the
biggest problem right now why do you
even have that sharklet just to kill it
he published pamphlets against us they
called it the great white snark
tilda swinton and her most daring role
yet
remember when Einstein going into a
house with a creepy Nutcracker was the
weird part
pretty normal everybody gets a bet
children Mary Poppins is about ready to
come down this family needs help give me
that doll you can't have him ever let me
explain something what I have to say
isn't easy it's movies awful okay
actually as easier than I thought
when you leave please will you take the
dolls hearse away with you me equals MC
fuck you
now are there any weapons at all
break I keep a small nuclear device in
this trunk
Uncle Albert gave it to me he says he's
working on it just in case he's looking
right at us rod breaks the fourth wall
she said that like she was a super
villain of this peril ah a young max
thanks need a little clarification if
you just saw him he like what is that
would you be like the Rat King
I thought hope undo it what what the
hell
[Music]
can you imagine having to work at the
theater that this played in to clean up
all the kids shits like Nutcracker 3d
played in here right yeah no don't do
anything again in this through the Nazi
class Sun is blocked out by smoke from
burning toys you do know the rats toys
you know maybe the ending of Toy Story 3
was actually a bigger allegory than we
thought
Jesus fuckin Christ
I mean Jesus fuckin Christ you know I
guess I should draw on the law to a
conclusion that Nazis and Nutcracker
would not be fun but yeah I am
legitimately shocked at how not fun this
is boys and girls
fucking christ shit whore fuck you in
every hole you have oh ha ha that little
dance it's funny cuz I'm thinking of all
the people that died go to one
Nutcracker
god that's the sense I never thought I
would say yeah do have fun little dance
just again thinking back to all the Jews
that died just go perfectly to get one
of the kids crying why do you have to
take this to dark places I I don't know
why your mind goes it's me clearly I
think remembering face off when Nicholas
Cage played John Travolta is in the
prison riot a skidding everyone outside
a steering that first split second he
cries he cracks that goes right back to
be crazy again
I just keep him at you - Turo doing that
now either oh wow we the rats
hey no Nutcracker in this nod we want to
totally burn any resemblance to
Nutcracker he who saves one toy saves
the toys our essence all right
now tear them limb from limb like
Mussolini jesus fucking christ
that fucking terrifying I know I can't I
just don't know how to take off that's
weirdly not exciting or interesting or
funny or it's not anything you are
showing us nothing and even when you
showing something it's awful it's awful
something a monkey's paw I'm gonna make
some wishes you forgot I'm a monkey we
cling tenaciously to things like your
cling tenaciously that this is a
nutcracker movie oh Christ
God God just god this is one of the
worst things I've ever seen
yeah it's way up there I see no the way
this can end except John gum and coming
out with a shotgun say oh this isn't no
other way you can then hiss John
Turturro I hope you don't mind but I
brought someone or not his name is Adolf
last night I suddenly realized that
everything is not relative it's all
magic just magic fuck sighs this movie
has shown me the way no I wish they
invent television
yeah we always joke about should always
list the musical well turns out somebody
made it famous just heinous that's the
best word I would use to describe it as
heinous I was at the partners like I
would not have been surprised if she
woke up and this is all a bad dream she
was having an Auschwitz like that is how
low this bar yeah like where you make us
a joke but it's like they could do that
they could fucking do that I hate using
the term bad taste cuz it's always like
cuz it's like I actually really love bad
taste I love bad taste shows if they're
done well I would have been no I
wouldn't care that it was in bad taste
if it was just a better fucking movie
there's just not right there's no
thought I still don't want to give it
the honor I'm still going Garbage Pail
Kids oh yeah no no no no just cuz like
and it's not it's pretty hottie up there
yeah maybe like this in the new top five
yeah I was gonna say maybe top five for
me that's about it somehow we gotta make
something of that oh this is gonna be
interesting
yeah I feel like this is South Park
where Jesus has to answer that question
he's like I'm not gonna touch that one
with a 10-foot Pole
that's what I want to be like right now
but we have to for you the vibe for you
you